increasing female achievement in
education and employment is one of the
primary driving forces that's
contributing to both The Mating crisis
and this birth Gap problem a very easy
rebuttal is are you saying that we
should roll back parity in education
which women only just achieve and you're
telling us that just after we've managed
to gain footing that we've been fighting
for for so long that you want us to stop
going to school no is the answer I mean
clearly that would be fundamentally
wrong I think we need to re-engineer the
education system for everybody frankly
the idea for example we graduate college
and we're kind of on the first rung of
the ladder looking for our first
position and that's going to Define our
career why can't people start their
career age 30. so starting a career at
age 30 or even 35 is fine you've still
got decades to kind of build up the
wealth I guess but you've got this
results in your career window as your
grandfather probably did in his